[Music]
jason is in washington d.c hi jason
welcome to the ramsey show
dave george how you guys doing today
better than we deserve brother what's
up man i've been pondering uh purchasing
a home here i've been looking into it
now for about six months or so
um actually was under contract and got
out but now i'm just
uh pondering the whole idea over again
and wondering if it's even something
that i should get into now or if i
should kind of hold off for a while and
save some more money so just
looking for some guidance there
are you out of debt
uh so i have uh sixteen thousand dollars
in student loan debt which is currently
not occurring interest i don't believe
it starts again until february i believe
that doesn't matter you need to pay it
off how much money do you have saved
how about 55 000 is that your only debt
i have a vehicle which i purchased a few
months ago i put 20 down on i owe about
23 000 on that
okay
we teach folks jason not to buy a house
until they're debt-free and have an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
plus a down payment you do not have that
much no you do not need to buy a house
right now you pay off your car pay off
your student loan build an emergency
fund and then build a down payment
how much of a down payment i mean 20
that's kind of i think what you i'd love
for you to have that because you avoid
pmi private mortgage insurance but on a
first-time home purchase i don't yell at
people for having less than that
yeah but i will yell at you for having a
car payment on a student loan when you
buy a house you're asking for trouble
right right
and i'll yell at you not only for the
entertainment value but just also uh to
help you
yeah now i understand please i enjoy the
entertainment as well
i'm messing with you but it's all good
brother the thing is this if you buy a
house with payments you are inviting
murphy to move into your spare bedroom
your transmission will go out the first
week
yeah yeah i could probably even if i
don't you know knock it all out at once
i could probably kind of chunk away at
the student loan debt in the vehicle
over the course of the next
year no no no you misunderstood you have
the money in the bank today to pay them
off
you're saying do it right now by the end
of the day brother
moment moments after you get off the air
you should be debt free
gotcha okay and then build an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
you ever heard of us talk about the baby
steps
i have i you know i tuned into you for a
while and then i stopped and i just have
to turn it on today and i i've been
listening for about the past two or
three hours two hours and i wanted to
give you a call yeah well you heard us
just describe it you heard us describe
it in the last segment right
i did i did
i actually took a couple notes oh that's
good well you know i took some notes
here too and you got 55 in cash and you
have 39 000 in debt which means you're
debt free today with about what 16 000
left over which may be an emergency fund
i don't know what that looks like for
you of three to six months of expenses
only then are you gonna start at zero
and start saving for this down payment
so i know it hurts because you've been
saving up this money but that money is
not down payment money that money is now
debt money that money's going towards
your emergency fund and then i want you
to start saving up
uh like dave said 20
towards that down payment and on top of
that i want you to do it within these
parameters i want you to do it on a
15-year fixed rate mortgage where the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay
what that's going to allow you to do is
do the other baby steps and have margin
in your life to where you can actually
enjoy things